der piperingehalt bestimmt die Qualität
von Pfeffer bei der gemahlenen Version
lässt sich jedoch ganz schön tricksen
Pfeffer oder nicht Pfeffer das ist hier
die Frage können Sie da einen
Unterschied feststellen ich glaube nicht
sebastian hat Pfeffer im Internet und
zeigt wie die Industrie mit gemahlenen
können mächtig verdient
[Musik]
Pfeffer der König der Gewürze super
beliebt in Deutschland und für die
Lebensmittelindustrie ein Bombengeschäft
Sebastian lege sieht sich genauer an was
Verbrauchern da in deutschen
Supermärkten angeboten wird er entdeckt
riesige Preisunterschiede
[Musik]
hier
schwarzer Kompott Pfeffer Kilo 130 Euro
. da wird eine banale passt da doch
gleich zum luxusgericht oder
[Gelächter]
die Preisunterschiede im pfefferregal
sind riesig der edle campott Pfeffer
kostet fast fünfmal so viel wie der von
Rewe
am billigsten ist jedoch gemahlener
Pfeffer knapp 16 € kostet das Kilo beim
Discounter das macht den Produkt
Entwicklern misstrauisch bei ganzem
Pfeffer
da lässt sich nicht viel tricksen aber
hier bei formalenem Pfeffer da kann man
mal ganz groß die trickschublade
aufziehen
riecht irgendwie alles auch gleich ne
ist schon wirklich komisch oder Piperin
heißt der Inhaltsstoff der Pfeffer so
einzigartig macht durch ihn wird Pfeffer
zu einem scharfen Gewürz von Natur aus
enthält Pfeffer 5 bis 10% Piperin
im Labor lassen wir zehn pfefferproben
auf ihren biberin Gehalt untersuchen
Resultat die Werte schwankende gewaltig
zwischen zwei und zehn Prozent Piperin
sind messbar
[Applaus]
für Pfeffer gibt es gesetzlich
eigentlich kaum Regulierungen der
piperingehalt der etwas über die
Qualität des Pfeffers nämlich über seine
Schärfe aussagt dafür gibt es keine
Vorgaben und das ist ein Problem denn
dann können Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher auch eine geringfügige
Qualität bekommen und das wird noch
nicht mal von den Behörden beanstandet
Piperin entsteht ganz natürlich in der
Pflanze Vietnam ist in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten zum größten pfefferexporteur
der Welt aufgestiegen
300.000 Tonnen wachsen hier pro Jahr
fast jedes zweite Pfefferkorn kommt aus
Vietnam
geerntet wird zweimal im Jahr grün also
unreif gepflückter Pfeffer enthält
relativ wenig peperien reift der Pfeffer
länger am Strauch steigt der
piperingehalt an
[Musik]
Pfeffer muss wochenlang trocknen und
wird dabei immer wieder gewendet das
Piperin konzentriert sich beim Trocknen
im Korn
Besserwisser Lilly Temme zeigt die
Lebensmittelindustrie hat den Wert von
Piperin neu entdeckt
[Musik]
hyperin ein echter super Stoff für
unseren Körper
hyperin wird zum Beispiel und sogar
entzündungshemmend und nicht nur da
im Gehirn wirkt es sich positiv auf
Stimmung Wohlbefinden und Appetit aus
und im Darm
unterstützten und Medikamenten
[Musik]
schon echt ein tolles Zeug dieses
hyperin inzwischen kann man das sogar
ganz ohne den Pfeffer drumherum
als Nahrungsergänzungsmittel kaufen und
das lohnt sich für die Hersteller in
dieser Kapsel hier steckt ungefähr
genauso viel peperien wie in dieser
Prise Pfeffer nur die kostet ungefähr
100 Mal so viel
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel versprechen
hochdosiertes Piperin soll dafür sorgen
dass der Körper die anderen Wirkstoffe
besser aufnehmen kann doch das hat
seinen Preis
bis zu
16.600 Euro verlangen die Hersteller pro
Kilo Piperin wenn sie es in Kapseln
verkaufen
in Form von Pfeffer kostet die gleiche
Menge gerade einmal
235 Euro
eine riesige Einnahmequelle für
trickreiche Lebensmittelproduzenten
Sebastian lege zeigt wie am Pfeffer
doppelt verdient werden kann
neidisch cooles Gerät ein
Rotationsverdampfer ist das war das
Wertvolle an diesem kleinen Körnern
[Musik]
Sebastian lege erhitzt Pfefferkörner auf
70 Grad bei dieser Temperatur löst sich
das Piperin aus dem Körnern und geht ins
Wasser über
also wir haben einmal hier das Produkt
das dampft jetzt hier aus steigt hier
hoch kühlt ab rutscht runter und hier
unten in dem kleinen
da kommt das pure gold raus aber das
muss jetzt natürlich erstmal aufsteigen
abkühlen runtertropfen
nach etwa 30 Minuten ist ein erstes
Ergebnis sichtbar
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt
perfekt pures Piperin
oh ja
[Gelächter]
yes und das Schöne ist ich habe jetzt
hier das pure Piperin aber hier wird er
nichts weggeschmissen nee nee nee nee
nee nee Pfefferkörner denen das Piperin
entzogen wurde dürfen nicht mehr als
Pfeffer verkauft werden doch wenn man
sie trocknet und mit einer Mühle in
Pulver verwandelt sehen sie aus wie
richtiger Pfeffer
[Musik]
dies könnte eine Erklärung sein warum
der piperingehalt bei Supermarkt Pfeffer
so auffallend gering ist
Pfeffer oder nicht die Frage
können Sie da einen Unterschied
feststellen ich glaube nicht
das ist auch anders geht zeigt ein Blick
nach Österreich in der Alpenrepublik
gibt es nämlich einen Piperin Grenzwert
mindestens 3,5% muss Pfeffer dort
enthalten
fünf von zehn getesteten Deutschen
pfefferproben liegen unter diesem
Grenzwert und dürften in Österreich so
gar nicht verkauft werden
dieser Trick zeigt es braucht gute
Regeln damit Verbraucher nicht von
schwarzen Schafen der Branche hinters
Licht geführt werden